student debt that's another thing he
wants to wipe out student debt because
it's still part of social justice
because black lesbians are in debt and
we've got to do something about it Bill
Maher wrecks him on that and Bill by the
way Bill likes birdie Bill's not trying
to wreck him Bill's trying to help him
in a bizarre way but Bernie Sanders
and again this is against white people
sometimes I think question some of what
you're saying this is a survey student
loan forgiveness recipient 73 percent of
applicants say they are likely to spend
their extra money on non-essential
including vacations smartphone drugs and
alcohol they admitted that to the
pollster who is this poster I at least
NBC News
52 percent they are very likely or
likely to buy new clothing 46 they would
use the money for vacation and eat out
at restaurants this is why people have a
thing about I I would never call it free
money oh I guess I just did
bill yeah you're right Bill you've
brought him on many times over the years
to spout his nonsense and and you now as
what I would say is a sane Lefty are
realizing that these endless bailouts
just giving people cash but it's not
giving people cash because you have to
take it from other people also we will
soon find out that it is completely
unconstitutional for the government to
just wipe out your debt I have 28 years
more mortgage on this house 30-year loan
I'd prefer not to pay it could someone
do something about that can we get Biden
on the phone can we get that cleared out
what do I need that on the books for
it's it's absolutely incredible so
Bernie doesn't believe in the poll he
also just part of being a socialist is
not understanding anything about basic
human psychology if you give a bunch of
19 year olds cash right you just give
them cash back they could get 100 Grand
back on the debts how much was it I
think it was 100 Grand right it was
going to max out at 100 Grand I think
the the debt for colleges whatever it is
even if it was 10 grand it doesn't it
doesn't even matter what the number is
and by the way whether it was seven
dollars or whether it was a hundred
thousand dollars it would still be
unconstitutional but let's put that
aside for a moment if you just give
people stuff whether it's subsidized
housing or whether it's food stamps
or whether it's cash because they spent
too much to get into a college that they
couldn't afford it doesn't mean that
they're all going to do the right thing
and get and and use that money
effectively most of them probably will
buy weed and they will buy video games
what are the kids playing these days
what Last of Us it's also a television
show thank you that's right up to twenty
thousand dollars by the way was what uh
the Biden Administration was proposing
they are going to use the money on a
whole bunch of stuff but Bernie doesn't
buy that because they don't understand
basic human psychology they just like
the very thin veneer the very thin
veneers we'd like to help these people
and these people it's I assume it's a
lot of minorities and the lesbians and
the people with one leg and we've got to
help them but if you don't think that
Bernie is a fraud Beyond human
imagination Beyond imagination who has
no balls by the way Bernie you have no
balls either Bernie from the movie had
more balls than you and he was
accomplishing a hell of a lot more and
he was dead
you got it you got it everyone got that
okay
um Bernie has no balls either because if
he had balls when Hillary Clinton
destroyed him and he and he actually had
the movement of the Democrat Party as
backwards and ridiculous as I think that
movement is he should have launched a
campaign against her right he should
have gone off and created a third party
that was his moment but he didn't he
backed her and now he's just on his
descent to nothingness
[Music]
foreign